hot breath comedians should think like
entrepreneurs
without a doubt please expand on that
well we don't we think like broke comics
we think about your work
it's a mindset and when i learned well i
tell you what i was
when i was doing my stand-up um i was
also teaching comedy traffic school
and which is a group i recommend this
for any comic who really wants to
have a captive audience first of all
you're working as an emcee
um you're you have to get a statement
mandated curriculum
out to the to this group of people while
making it humorous
what a great training ground for eight
hours so i was doing this
and i know it was going well because
there's a when we'd have like a
wednesday thursday evening class the
second night i had a dude show up with
his wife he goes i brought my wife
i go why it's date night this is a
traffic school you know he goes yeah but
it was so much fun last night you're
cool with it right i go sure
bring her in and so um it was whatever
was i was obviously getting laughs and
they were still learning the material
and so uh that for me helped me to
uh branch out to doing warm-up for
television shows
because perfect same thing basically and
then
uh what i did was i was i had this guy
in one of my
traffic schools who was president of the
chamber of commerce and he came up to me
and he said
i'm the president of the chamber of
commerce he was there for rolling a stop
sign
and he said we do an annual dinner every
chamber in the united states does one of
these where they swear out the
old officers and swear in the new i
would love you to emcee it
and do 30 minutes to stand up i'll pay
you 800 and give you beer
and i was in college at the time and i
thought
broke you know and i thought beer i'm in
and um
so i did did the event it went really
well
i got a videotape of it i hired a
videographer right
which was 600 bucks at the time
investing in yourself and uh so
i made 200 total on the gig and
got that video and then two weeks later
the neighboring
uh city's chamber of commerce called me
and said uh hey i heard you did a great
job over at chico would you come and do
hours
how much do you charge me i thought the
going rate would
eight was 800 i didn't know i could
negotiate so i took the gig
and i thought to myself how many
chambers of commerce are there in the
united states
7 650 and i had to go down to the
library
to get that data because we didn't have
the internet back then
and so i basically got a database for
200 of them in the region of northern
california
sent out flyers via fax with me at the
deus
at the chico chamber of commerce saying
change your annual dinner to an event
hire a professional comedian to emcee
and i got a bunch of phone calls that
came in i booked 28 in a three month
period all at 800
and i said i've got a career
i've got a business and so that's how i
started
going out and doing corporates i love
the catharsis of doing the clubs
but the clubs don't pay like corporates
do oh no so then i was able to up my
dollar amount for other corporate events
and then i said what is the chamber of
commerce it's an association
how many associations are there in the
united states too many to count but
according to
one of the databases that track
associations there is like
uh 2.3 million all wanting a comedian to
do their event they just don't know it
yet
they don't know how it fits but with the
chamber of commerce
since i knew they did annual dinners and
most
most of the time they can't find the
person that really wants to emcee it
that's their pain point and so i offer a
solution to the pain point
just like every commercial does right
you know pain point pain point pain
point
solution that's how you sell something
right so
um just and when i was becoming a
comedian booking myself i got a sales
um kit you know how to be how to be a
good salesman
because i knew i'm gonna have to sell
myself that's i hate sales but
i might as well learn the techniques
entrepreneur and that helped me to book
that helped me to book a lot of stuff
and that helped me to get it to get a
manager an agent because i was already
working
you know i went in and show them how
much i'm working they said yeah we want
to sign you
it's funny you say chamber of commerce
because i did a chamber of commerce
event last year and you're making me
think
i need to email every chamber of
commerce in the region
now
they need to know what if they know
where it fits
how does it fit how is it a solution for
us because if you just say
comedy they're like okay what comedy
where's it fit but if you find a place
where it could fit
like mc for their annual dinner that
fits
what if and so i said hmm what can i do
and i read this thing in a
business journal that said the
california companies small businesses
were facing you know 28 million dollars
in settlements
legal a liability settlements for sexual
harassment lawsuits
and so i came up with a 20-minute
routine
on how to alleviate sexual harassment or
how to recognize it and alleviate it
uh you got to know what it is first
before you alleviate it um
and i prepared it a humorous sort of
thing
basically a stand-up act with us with a
speech so information laden
with a lot of humor points built in and
then uh
did a uh offered a free luncheon to the
rotary club
and they had me in i did a free i said
the caveat is don't tell anybody it's
free
and so i delivered this 20-minute thing
on tolerance in the workplace
and pitched it from the angle of pain
point 28 million dollars in liabilities
how many of your small business owners
are prepared for this um
i can deliver this thing on on on
alleviating sexual harassment in the
workplace by developing tolerance
and so i went up and delivered this
thing
25 minutes they loved it 15 20 people
gave me business cards hey we gotta have
we have a christmas party we have a golf
tournament we have this we have
this and i booked all these gigs so they
came to me with that
you know it sounds like the
entrepreneurs thinking like
entrepreneurs means
think outside of just the comedy club
structure yeah
absolutely where else can you apply this
public speaking skill i mean starting
your own show is a way
yep but also finding there's events
everywhere there's birthday parties
there's family reunions like think
outside of
we get there's the old school we're like
but you gotta
rise the ranks of the comedy club but
it's like the business of comedy is way
beyond
just trying to mc feature then headline
a comedy club
so far beyond in fact and and just a
little a note i don't say any of this to
brag
uh because money to me is just a result
of you doing
something positive it really is i think
if you keep it that way you never have
the ups and downs of success and failure
you have the joy of doing the work for
the sake of the work my dad taught me
that as an actor
and i lived by it so in this case
word got out that i was teaching comedy
there was this doctor in my
one of my lots of my classes he loved
what i did
and he gave the word he gave the word to
the director of kaiser director of
kaiser
for west la called me and said jerry
i'm thinking about i'm doing a seminar
where i'd like to teach doctors to use
humor in the workplace
because i want their clinic to visit
visits to be more like you know house
calls
can you help doctors develop a sense of
humor in the
in the clinic visit i said that's right
down my alley
and so we had a couple of phone calls
and he said how much
i said five thousand dollars he said no
problem he said i'm going to run it by
the board
first he said is that all and i went
he's like 7 000. yeah no problem so he
said oh that's just
for me showing up right right yeah can't
change it then
but what happened they passed on me so
three days later a week later i get this
call from this guy
who's uh they and he called me up he
said you know they went with some monkey
muck from cisco or
toxin from oracle and all these big
companies so um
but uh his name is dan something or
other so this guy calls me up named dan
saying he needs help on how to use humor
uh can he can i coach him on that
because he's got a speech for kaiser
he's talking to 200 doctors in the
morning 200 in the afternoon
and they're paying him 40 000 forty
forty thousand
so i said i can help you with that he
goes how much will that cost me go five
thousand dollars
because i wanted to make back the money
i lost
so he agreed and he was miserable as a
student he was
arrogant he refused to adapt
things and learn you know jerry i don't
need to self-deprecate
i know i'm very knowledgeable and i
research my stuff and i'm good at what i
do
i said but you're talking to doctors
they need to know that you don't feel
you're superior to them
because they're doctors so if you
self-deprecate just a little bit
they'll trust you more he still refused
i said you know what i can't work with
you
so just give me half and good luck
six months later i get the call from the
director of kaiser he said uh that guy
um he didn't do so well uh
so he wasn't he didn't live up to our
expectations do you still
are you still willing to come help us
out with this event uh
yes sure is your fee still five thousand
dollars i said no sir
it's now forty thousand and he said i'm
just curious
why is it more uh i said well because
you
you worked with a guy and he didn't do
it for you and you paid him forty
thousand
he goes how do you know he called me up
for coaching
and he was miserable to coach with he
goes i
i can i can see that he said i have no
problem with the price in fact the board
might like it more because that sounds
more more legit to them
and that opened my mind to how we think
about
money and how other people think about
money
comedians think about money as like as
oh my god i got a piece
of gold i'm going to hold on to it
forever right because we don't there's
not a lot of it going around
yeah but these guys think of money in a
whole different way
dropping 40 000 for an afternoon
wow and then what they were trying to do
is get this to go national as a program
for kaiser
so they were in contact with the
director of national kaiser who's in
hawaii
and then what happened is he now retired
so
it's kind of a dead issue to have to
reignite it and get it back going again
but if you can you know think i i had no
idea i could ever get paid that much for
one event
never you know and when that happened i
went that's a whole new world
they probably passed on you because it
was so low that's right exactly
right exactly 40 000 and it gave me a
whole different way of looking
at it we think if somebody if we're if
we quote too much
they're just going to run away and then
no they usually counter
because they're not as emotional towards
money as we are
yeah we're like oh fifty dollars in
chicken wings
okay yeah yeah how far the five-hour
drive yeah yeah yeah i'll do it i'll do
it for the experience
in the mic time of course and i did a
lot of that stuff always yeah
i drove for you know just to have the
get the mic time somewhere
encounter a new book or do something for
free oh of course you know
i use my uh cause because i had kids i
used the
the uh sort of the my tax refund which
is usually about somewhere around four
thousand dollars
and i put that into a travel fund and
i'd use that money
to go uh i would book one-nighter gigs
and fly to the one-nighter gigs and then
in the breaks i'd i'd map out and do
uh uh i'd call up and set up guest spots
at the a clubs and sort of use that
beast like a salesman on the road
you know and you know if i can go there
and where and do a guest spot
uh for free and show them my wares you
know
hey here's my vacuums you know good idea
so it's basically thinking like an
entrepreneur
and a uh and think about this as your
comedy enterprise rather than thinking
as a comedian with your
it gives you a whole different level of
commitment to it too you're not actually
sitting there with your hat
out you're sitting there with with a as
a business person
you know saying we have a mutually
beneficial business arrangement rather
than please i need the gig you know it's
just all
they look at you differently when you
approach it like that